yes this Hall includes part of the
shopping hey everybody how's it going
hope you are well
so we're doing a very special type of
video today that I've been wanting to do
for a long time and before we start I
wanted to say thank you to Best Buy for
sponsoring today's video so today we're
doing a haul video where I'm gonna talk
about a ton of products but it's all
kind of centered around this like when
you're going into a new life stage maybe
you're starting college maybe you're
starting your first job there's just a
couple products that are really useful
to have both from building your career
and also enjoying yourself outside of
work and so I wanted to introduce some
of those products to you in college I
kind of paid for all of my own stuff and
so I couldn't really buy a ton of stuff
but there were a couple of things that I
bought that were so useful and also a
couple of things that I had wish I
bought because it really would have made
my life better
hindsight is twenty-twenty and so now I
have a list of things I wish I had buy
and also a list of things that I did buy
and I would totally buy again because it
really made my college experience and
post-grad life experience much better so
we are going to go on a little shopping
spree together and we're gonna go to
Best Buy to buy all this stuff let's do
it
[Music]
Oh keywords Oh but these are gaming
keyboards NEP keyboards are nice though
they're very clucky oh I like the feel
of this one oh I have cherry blues at
work so it feels like this one can you
hear it
depending on the key type it's very
different
oh I definitely had oh man fridges were
so important for college they were kept
all night
like leftovers and all the food that I
got from home from my mom and everyone
[Music]
I was like the first level Yahoo
skyline's did a marathon of Doctor Who
when I was in college that was like my
show that I watched which one did you
like more my favorite doctor was David
Tennant but I also really liked Peter
Capaldi all right we are back from Best
Buy it's actually been a couple of days
because movie magic and I've been kind
of using some of the stuff that I bought
so let's jump into it and talk about the
products that I ended up buying so the
first two products that I want to talk
about are ones that I definitely
invested in in college and also after
college I almost wish I'd invested in
them more but they're related to a dev
setup at home the reason why I think
these two items are really important is
because when you're in college sometimes
you don't want to go to the labs I know
that I got sick every time I went to the
labs because it wasn't the most cleanest
place and after college I found it
really beneficial to have an at-home dev
setup because then I can work from home
I can also bring my work home if I
needed to and it just gave me kind of
another place to build my skills so the
first thing I wanted to talk about is
this mouse right here this is the
Logitech MX master 2s I really really
like having kind of this external mouse
to use for programming Simon's for just
anything I did have a Logitech mouse
when I was in college that I used all
the time I think I just prefer mouse
movements because it feels more
ergonomic and my wrists don't start
hurting so it was really important for
me to get that this one is kind of your
typical mouse has a lot of functionality
and like all other Logitech Mouse's
they're programmable which I really like
the other thing I really like about this
is that you can switch between different
computers I go between lots of different
computers especially now because I have
a personal laptop and a work laptop so
just having a one-size-fits-all solution
is something that I really wanted and I
would totally buy this if I was in
college and I'm glad that I bought it
now the other thing that I bought which
I can't really show you here but there
will be roll is a external monitor I
think having an external monitor is one
of those really useful things especially
when you're coding because coding takes
up a lot of screen real estate so having
another thing other than whatever you're
working off of a laptop or a desktop
computer it's really useful I picked up
the LG 27 inch 4k monitor I really like
this one it's really sleek it doesn't
take up that much room and I really
wanted something in a high resolution
since the higher the resolution the more
you can fit on your screen I definitely
had an external monitor when I was in
college but because I couldn't afford
like an actual one I ended up using like
my friend's 20 inch TV that you no
longer needed which worked but it
definitely hurt my eyes so that's one of
those things that I kind of wish I
invested in early on I did end up
getting an external monitor later on in
my first year of working but that has
like having an external monitor just
changes the whole organ AMA can
experience of programming and just using
a computer the next two products that
I'm going to talk about our music
related I get a lot of energy from music
like I feel like it sets the mood and
vibe of what I'm feeling and helps me
get stuff done so whether it be cleaning
or doing homework or doing laundry or
driving I'm kind of one of those people
that always need to have music on in the
background so I'm excited to show you
two products today two to two products
today that I really like so the first
product is the JBL true free wireless
headphones they come in this neat little
case which is also the charger of this
and then when you open it up
headphones are these are truly wireless
headphones which are really nice because
they don't get tangled up in anything
they have some buttons on the side so
you can kind of control your music and
stuff which is really cool when I was in
college I definitely brought headphones
with me wherever I went
whether it be to drown out excess noise
or just to like get in the mood of
studying or something
so having like really wireless
headphones is super helpful just to kind
of be able to go on the move but these
are also really great gym headphones
they're very secure and so I'm really
happy with them and the battery life is
actually quite good so that is the first
product the second product is this one
this is the JBL portable boombox speaker
and I'm gonna put it down because I'm
not that fit I like having a speaker
system wherever I'm living at the time
because again I just really like chimney
up to music all the time so whether I
was living in a dorm or an apartment of
corporate housing just having something
that helps me play music in a really
high-quality way was important to me
it's really cool because it has really
good battery life there's 24 hours of
non-stop playback which that's a long
time so you can keep the party going but
based on this is also really nice like
it has two subwoofers on the side and so
it gives a very rich sound and I'm a fan
of it and it's just bluetooth so any
device can basically hook into it so the
next product is kind of a fun and social
one this is the HP sprocket photo
printer it comes in all these really
cute colors and it chose the thick one
cuz I thought it was fun and it's really
small and I'm I liked it very cute I
really like this because basically you
can take a photo with any phone and
phones nowadays have amazing cameras and
you can just print them here you can
print personalized photos and stickers
and it's awesome because multiple people
can connect to this device and print at
once which is a 2nd edition new feature
and also another really cool thing is
that it adds AI to bring everything to
life which is a part of the app and I
think that's really cool it feels very
2019 that like your photo is not just a
photo anymore
it's an entire experience that you can
have yeah I think we live in the future
I also definitely would have decorated
my dorm with this so okay so there is
one more kind of social related product
and this is the DJI Osmo pocket when I
was in college and when I graduated
personal vlogging became more of a thing
just vlogging your travels blogging
times with your friends and so having
something like that to just capture all
the memories in video form I think is
kind of cool and I actually should do
more of that in my current state to day
life because I will forget those
memories otherwise this one I really
like because it has a camera and a
gimbal built in and it has a screen and
a whole entire system involved I feel
like buying these individual pieces
alone can cost like $1,000 but this was
under $500 which I feel like it's super
reasonable and it's also really tiny so
it's easy to travel with my husband and
I are traveling to Europe this summer so
I'm really excited to bring this instead
of like an entire camera setup and yeah
I am just so excited about this like
it's so small next year products are
literally for some just personal
enjoyment and fun they are to gaming
products feeling in college is really
when I left the bow of gaming entirely
because I was just so busy and after I
graduated was when the intend o 3ds came
out and I've been much more interested
in some of this stuff and there's new
technologies for gaming that are
arriving which i think is super cool the
first product is by no means a new
product or anything but I just really
like it it is the Nintendo switch I've
always really liked Nintendo products
and games because I feel like their
interactions and their games and
mechanics and games are all just so
different I also like the fact that it's
count co-op and so you can literally
invite your friends and play games
I'm also the type to not play kind of
scary first-person shooter type of games
and I'm way more into like puzzle games
and stuff like that and I feel like
Nintendo has a huge variety of games
like that so I'm excited to finally have
my own the next product that I have is
something that I don't think those
around when I was in college but it is
all the craze now so I'm excited to try
it out it is the oculus quest this is a
brand new product from oculus it is an
all-in-one vr gaming product so you
don't need a computer or anything to
render anything which is different from
past VR headsets where you did have to
have a really powerful computer in
addition to the VR headset do you want
to play games but this one this is like
this is literally all you need and I'm
just amazed that there's an entire like
computer in here that can render 3d
worlds for VR cuz like it's not that big
and it just it's incredible there was a
game development class I was offered as
part of the computer science program
which I ended up not taking because I
heard it was really demanding but I'm
really curious about how VR development
is I actually haven't done very much
game development at all but I think with
things like unity and other rendering
and gaming engines and frameworks it can
be pretty fun it's also got these cool
clicky button thingies what are these
called controllers they're called
controllers and the last product that I
wanted to talk about is what I think of
as an essential necessity for not just
college not just after college but just
in general really make your life better
and that's a smartphone in this case I
have a samsung galaxy s 10 it's a really
really nice phone and it's got a really
nice camera in college when I was
communicating with other friends or just
checking up on my email or homework or
something most of it was done through
apps and so I know that y'all have
smartphones but I really can't stress
enough like how important it is to have
one because it really does make your
life better and not just any smartphone
to getting a really high quality
smartphone is going to make a huge
difference because you'll notice it in
the speed I'm going to say it in how
quickly the memory fills up and just the
usage and the dynamics and just the
comfort of using one and so getting kind
of a high quality phone like this one is
really important
fun fact I think the app that I use the
most in college was Kakao Talk
which is a really popular messaging app
from Korea we use it because all of us
had different kinds of phones and so
just having one type of messaging
platform to talk to everybody on was
really important and it was fun because
it was like the early days of having
stickers and stuff like that all right
that is it for today thank you so much
for watching I will leave a link to all
these products in the description box
below and I really wanted to say thank
you so much the Best Buy for sponsoring
today's video as you saw in the video I
went to the local Best Buy to buy all of
this stuff and literally everybody at
Best Buy all the blue shirts were so
helpful that I feel like as soon as I
started kind of wandering around and
trying to find something they were right
there and helping me and they were just
so gracious and like checking stock for
everything too which doesn't happen at
all stores and so I felt like I was
really being taken care of and the fact
that I can just like walk into a store
and get the thing immediately was
awesome granted there were a couple
things that weren't in stock in store
but were online and Best Buy has an
amazing fast store pickup policy and so
I got these products shipped to my local
best buyer really quickly and I got to
pick it up and it was just so easy to do
all of that one of the things that I
no Best Buy did but it's something that
I love when retailers do is price match
guarantee and so if you find a product
with a lesser price from a store that is
a key online or local competitor to Best
Buy then they will match the price
online and lastly I know that a lot of
girl who are watching our students and
Best Buy has a lot of student deals you
can get additional savings to buy things
at Best Buy it's exclusive to students
so you can get the best deals on school
tech which I think this is actually
maybe one of the things that I miss the
most about being a student getting all
these like cool deals and stuff for
things that you need for school if
you're interested at Tech student deals
2 3 3 2 2 1 1 to sign up today alright
so again thanks so much for watching
don't forget to hit subscribe and like
this video to let me know that you are
into this type of content and like me
and stuff social validation is much
appreciated and I will see you next time
Thanks bye
[Music]